hello my name is Philip and this is
let's talk religion I'm a graduate
student in the academic field of
comparative religion currently working
on my master's thesis about West African
Sufism and in fact I have specialized
primarily in Sufism and an Islam
generally and on this channel I'll be
uploading educational as well as
hopefully entertaining videos about
everything related to the subject so
there will be short videos about basic
concepts like religion itself God
theology politics and so on there will
be more in-depth historical reviews
about certain historical figures or
individuals like the ones already
uploaded on open to fail or even hundun
for example and there'll also be some
longer really cool documentaries about
certain local religious groups the
subject of religion has become an
increasingly important aspect of our
social and political debates but in
spite of this not a lot of people know
too much about it and the complexities
that are part of it and so the aim of
this channel is to at least for some of
you illuminate some of those
complexities and give you a greater
understanding and grasp of the subject
of religion and the way it affects
society and in general and to do this
from an academic perspective so feel
free to subscribe and check out the rest
of the channel and hopefully I'll see
you in a future video thank you
[Music]